es ist 20 21 baltes mal und dann sehe
ich in die wahlkabine die dritte episode
von diesen parteien dingsbums leute
folge drei unserer parteien charts und
achtung jetzt wird es voll extrem wir
stellen euch die sechs parteien vor die
wahrscheinlich das nächste parlament
bilden werden und heute sind wir ganz am
rand unterwegs ganz links ganz ganz
rechts die linke und die fdp hier wieder
die ältere partei zuerst die linke rund
60.000 mitglieder durchschnitt 54 jahre
frauenanteil um die 36 prozent stehen
für umverteilung vermögenssteuer
spitzensteuersatz auf
erbschaftssteuerrecht direkte demokratie
volksentscheid keine massentierhaltung
keine bundeswehr auslandseinsätze
auflösung der nato ein für alle bus- und
waren umsonst kitas umsonst die wurzeln
der linken liegen in der ddr
dort regierte die sed die sozialistische
einheitspartei deutschlands und
mitregieren meine ich wirklich regieren
seit 1968 stand in der ddr verfassung
sinngemäß wir sind eine demokratie aber
bei wahlen gewinnt immer die sed
man muss vielleicht dabei gewesen sein
ddr halt unrechtsstaat diktatur
keiner durfte in den westen ausreisen
bis zu diesem berühmten zitate war das
ist das sofort unter zügig kennt ihr ja
aus der schule
kurz darauf geht der ganze booms unter
die ddr ist geschichte und kommt mit
sicherheit nicht wieder die nun völlig
nutzlose sed benannte sich um in pds und
erster vorsitzender wurde der letzte sed
vorsitzende gregor gysi
noch 1997 waren 98 prozent der pds
mitglieder früher in der sed oder in der
fdj gewesen es war quasi eine rein
ostdeutsche partei wird es nur wenn man
genau hinsieht kann man es heute noch
erahnen hier die linken ergebnisse bei
der letzten bundestagswahl
damit lassen sich natürlich keine wahlen
im bund gewinnen die pds kam damals in
den bundestag verlor aber immer mehr
wähler 2002 waren nur noch diese beiden
abgeordneten übrig ganz traurig 2007
fusionierte die pds mit der
westdeutschen wahlalternative soziale
gerechtigkeit damals war der begriff
alternative noch positiv besetzt eine
verrückte zeit in der wsg war auch ein
prominenter spd flüchtling oskar
lafontaine
ihm war die spd nicht mehr links genug
er fühlte sich hier eher zu hause aus
diesen beiden parteien wurde 2007 die
linke 14 jahre jung süß und wie alle
teenager sehr überzeugt von ihren
idealen die überwindung des kapitalismus
aber kapitalismus das ist doch dass mit
den schönen schuhen und den handtaschen
und den iphones und dem ganzen zu
überwinden
trotzdem die gesamtdeutsche linke war
deutlich erfolgreicher 2009 zogen sie
mit fast 12 prozent in den bundestag ein
ein jahr später wurden sie das erste mal
aus dem unterricht geworfen weil 50
linken abgeordnete gegen den krieg in
afghanistan protestieren 2011 schreiben
die vorsitzenden gesine lötzsch und
klaus ernst einen geburtstagsbrief
fidel castro zum 85 kaum zu glauben aber
wahr der fidel wird heute 85 jahre alles
gute
rossi gysi und klaus b s sollen wir dir
was aus dem kapitalismus schicken café
oder kuh regatta ziemlich dämliche
aktion gregor gysi wurde bis 2014 vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet was im
nachhinein allen beteiligten sehr
peinlich war
schwamm drüber bodo ramelow wurde auch
vom verfassungsschutz beobachtet was im
nachhinein beteiligten peinlich war
schwamm drüber ramelow wurde 2014 erster
linker ministerpräsident in thüringen
mein name ist bodo ramelow ich komme als
regierungschef auch bei der nächsten
landtagswahl wurde die linke mit abstand
stärkste kraft das hat die thüringer hfg
so dermaßen aufgeregt dass sie mit einem
miesen trick den dummen fdp-kandidaten
entschuldigung mit einem dummen trägt
den miesen fdp-kandidaten kemmerich zum
ministerpräsidenten machte obwohl der
gerade so über die fünf prozent gekommen
war absolut würdelose aktion auf die
linken frau susanne hennig welt so
völlig korrekt reagiert
die anderen optionen waren blumenstrauß
anzünden und blumenstrauß in die fresse
heute ist sie zusammen mit janine
wissler parteivorsitzende der linken in
bremen sitzt die linke seit 2009 10
erstmals in einem westdeutschen land mit
in der regierung
also bremen sieht aus als fast schon
immer von der linken regiert aber
trotzdem das sind echte sozialisten also
so richtig oldschool karl marx rosa
luxemburg da gibt's auch noch echte
kommunist die meinen die ddr war ein
legitimes experiment das man ruhig noch
mal wiederholen könnte und natürlich
vielen lifestyle
sozialismus gerne wenn ich meine
espressomaschine und meinen tesla
behalten darf ich die linke ist längst
keine ddr parteien schon 2017 gab es
mehr mitglieder in west als in
ostdeutschland
ironie der geschichte kommen wir zu
einer uhr westdeutschen partei die mehr
erfolg in ostdeutschland hat die afg
rund 32.000 mitglieder
durchschnittsalter unbekannt
wahrscheinlich frauenanteil 18 prozent
stehen für keine ausländer kein
klimaschutz co2 ist super atomkraft ist
super wir vielleicht wieder einführen
europa innerhalb der euro katastrophe
hier für alle igitt keine ausländer
keine ausländer hatten wir zwei mal da
müssen wir ein spa ziehen die afg ist
die jüngste der sieben großen parteien
2013 gegründet als reine anti euro
partei damals noch mit parteichef bernd
lucke die wollten damals zurück zur
d-mark weil schon mal gefragt
unser ganzes geld nach griechenland geht
somit sind unsere kaputten straßen und
brücken
weil die griechen nicht mit geld umgehen
können
bekloppte idee die d-mark war nur halb
so viel wert wie der euro
damit holten sie 2013 aus dem stand 4,7
prozent im bund ein jahr später kamen
sie ins europaparlament und in drei
landtage der erfolg lockte alle
möglichen rechten und ultra rechten
spinner an bernd lucke versuchte noch
den großen rechtsruck irgendwie
aufzuhalten wurde aber aus seiner
eigenen partei gemobbt der typ war
einfach zu naiv von anfang an gab es
schnittmengen mit den islam hasser der
rechten pedal bewegung aber in der afg
ist für jeden was dabei
es gibt eu skeptiker und neoliberale
aber auch national konservative
christliche fundamentalisten fanatische
abtreibungsgegner autoritär völkisch
nationale homophobe antifeministen
antisemiten und geschichtsrevisionismus
d-mark kein klimaschutz eine
erbschaftssteuer kein ländern und keine
zugang 2015 bekamen sie unfreiwillig
wahlhelfer quasi geschenkt menschen
flohen aus kriegsgebieten und wussten
gar nicht dass sie wahlkampf für die afg
machten die konnte ihr glück kaum fassen
die grenzen nicht schließen dann werden
wir eine kulturelle kernschmelze
der damals gar nicht betroffene
alexander gauland erinnert sich die
illegale öffnung der grenzen da war mir
klar
hier läuft die grenzen wurden zwar gar
nicht aufgemacht weil die waren auf im
seit langem vereinigten europa man kann
nicht aufmachen was gar nicht zu ist
jörg morton will weg vom zitat links
rot-grün versifften 68er deutschland hin
zu einem wehrhaften nationalstaat und
beatrix von storch befürwortete sogar
den schusswaffengebrauch gegen
flüchtlinge aber keine angst nur gegen
volljährige flüchtlinge bernd hocke doch
bernd oder im links-grünen versetzten
zdf habe ich immer bernd hocke gehört
auf luke scheiterte mit seinen versuchen
parteimitglieder wie bernd hocke
loszuwerden
der türke redet vom holocaust mahnmal
als denkmal der schande von dem licher
bewältigung politik und dass deutschland
eine erinnerungs politische wende um 180
grad braucht seitdem hat heute in der
gedenkstätte des kz buchenwald
hausverbot
das musste erst mal hinkriegen die
aktuelle spitzenkandidatin alles weidl
meint walkers kopftuchmädchen und
alimentierte messer männer und würzige
taugenichts werden unseren wohlstand
der sozialstaat nicht sicher
der ehrenvorsitzende alexander gauland
meint freunde
sie sind nur ein frisches ich gebe zu es
ist ein bisschen redundant noch
irgendwas was nichts mit flüchtlingen
oder holocaust zu tun hat co2 ist nicht
schlecht fürs klima sondern
unverzichtbarer bestandteil allen lebens
so kann man es auch sehen und damit holt
man dann 12,6 prozent bei der letzten
bundestagswahl drittstärkste fraktion
und schauen wir uns mal die zweitstimmen
verteilung an
da kann ich nichts auffälliges entdecken
offenbar gibt es einen markt für rechtes
und ganz recht ist
die alternative ist seit 2013 nicht mehr
an der fünf-prozent-hürde gescheitert
sie sitzt in allen landtagen
das können weder die grünen noch die fdp
von sich behaupten man kann sagen die
afg hat vor acht jahren
rechtskonservativ angefangen ist dann
massiv nach rechts gerückt und driftet
seitdem immer weiter richtung ultra
rechts ab
im märz hat das bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz die gesamte partei als
rechtsextrem verdachtsfall eingestuft
und das sind die spitzenkandidaten
dieses verdachtsfall sie alice weidl und
tino keller
jetzt bin ich glaube ich durch mit der
afg oder von mir aus hausverbot im kz
ist das für den rechten eigentlich eine
strafe oder eine auszeichnung
[Musik]
nochmal zur veranschaulichung ich stehe
jetzt gerade massiv rechts im bild
und jetzt jetzt stehe ich ultrarechts
das ist dieser afd drift versteht ihr
das so abonnieren nicht vergessen da
muss man einfach hier klicken
oder hier wenn ihr weitere videos sehen
wollt